Speaker 1: And speaking of Democrats pushing
much needed legislation this week, several
Democratic members in the House of Representatives
and in the Senate have proposed excuse me,
legislation called the Right to Vote Act and
what the Right to Vote Act, which let's give
credit here.
You got Representative Mondher Jones, Senators
John Office and Alex Padilla.
They introduced this piece of legislation
on Wednesday.
What it would do is would ensure that courts
respect the right to vote as the fundamental
right that it is.
It is the first congressional guarantee of
the right to vote in federal elections.
It also solves the problem that we are seeing
in certain states of elections, subversion.
The bill would affirm American's right to
vote by declaring election laws or rules that
pose a severe or discriminatory burden to
be illegitimate unless the jurisdiction in
question can prove that that its proposed
law or rule furthers a governmental interest
and is the least restrictive means of doing
so.
So once again, we have Democrats in the House
and in the Senate.
That are saying we have to do something to
protect the right to vote for Americans.
You know, what is it, close to 200 pieces
of legislation being worked on across the
country.
We all know Texas right now is trying to be
the latest to pass a massively restrictive
voting bill.
George has already done it.
Florida's already done it.
Other states are trying to get it done as
well.
Federal legislation could circumvent this
federal legislation, could render all of these
other pieces dead.
Here's the problem.
In some of the areas where this legislation
has passed, and I'm not saying this would
be effective, I'm just saying this is a possibility.
You have states that have already passed these
restrictive voting bills.
If the federal government were to come out
with federal legislation basically undoing
these state bills, the states would actually
have a pretty decent 10th Amendment case to
bring against the government.
You know, you didn't have a law in place,
so we put our own in place.
And so hours existed prior to yours, it may
not be the strongest legal argument, but I
guarantee you we would see it coming out of
these states.
You know, the states rights groups would be
fighting this tooth and nail.
Doesn't mean it would be successful.
Just means if something like the Right to
Vote Act did end up passing, it would still
have a long journey through the U.S. courts
before finally becoming law of the land, to
be honest, or possibly even being struck down
by the United States Supreme Court.
That, as we all know, has a huge conservative
slant right now.
But all of that is future talk.
And there's a time for future talk and there's
a time to just acknowledge that, yes, Democrats
are actually working to do good things for
the United States.
And sometimes you just got to take a win when
you can get a win, and sometimes that win
is just the draft legislation, whether it's
the right to Vote Act, whether it's that,
you know, five hundred billion dollar fine
that Sanders and Warren want to levy against
fossil fuel companies.
A win is a win.
Corey Bush.
With her protest essentially to extend the
eviction moratorium that worked.
We may only get an extra 60 days of an eviction
moratorium, but direct action produced a result
and Democrats are not sitting idly by, some
of them, because we all know some of them
are, but some of them are not sitting idly
by in Washington, D.C., watching as Republicans
strip voting rights away from constituents
because that's the only way they can stay
in power.
They've admitted that too many times over
just the past year for us to not acknowledge
that, that is why this is happening.
Republicans know that the public changes.
Demographic shift, people's viewpoints change.
Look at polling on issues stripped away from
politicians or political parties and on the
issues, America is actually very progressive.
That only changes when you attach a political
ideology or a specific politician to the policy,
by the way, something to keep in mind when
you see these numbers.
Americans support these things.
Republicans support these things.
They support the infrastructure bill.
They support action to to reign in climate
change.
They support raising taxes on corporations.
The wind is at your back, Democrats, I want
to see more of this.
Not just because I want you to prove that
you can fight.
But because I actually have a vested interest
as an American in watching everybody's lives
get better.
Unfair and cousins and for David Pakman.
We'll be right back